did you guys know the prophet peace be
upon him
said peace be upon him said the one who
gives him his will be a shade on and we
here every Friday and Sunday doing da to
many people seven Shas two weeks
ago two Shas last two Shas last week you
can support this brother and sisters
with the material alhamdulillah some of
them we pay for some of them aldah we
get for free as you guys donated to the
Salah plus project alamah brothers and
sisters if you can donate whatever you
can it will help our operations to have
a cameraman an editing team and some of
the brothers who come here and dedicate
their time and effort to giving da inah
the link is in the description box
[Music]
below how are you guys doing we've seen
some very scary things in the news Zan
and it seems like in the UK people are
trying to Target kids it's not the
perpetrators that these people are you
know hoping maybe it would be Muslim
perpetrators uh it turns out to be
actually Christian perpetrators not to
say that that's a connection with the
faith here but what's going on and what
happened recently with this thing in
leester square tell us yeah just a
couple of days ago Leicester Square is
an absolute Hotpot of tourists and there
was a guy in his 30s Romanian can't even
speak English properly mhm this guy
stabbed an 11-year-old girl and a 34y
old woman the 11year old girl he stabbed
eight times what a vile
disgusting disgusting despicable act and
as this was happening and people are
there with their phones minding their
own business a hero an unsung hero
capeless Crusader Abdullah who's a
migrant who's Asian and Muslim his name
ironically Abdullah means slave of Allah
so this slave of Allah because in the
riots they're saying who the f is Allah
this slave of Allah ironically is the
one that's jumping on the perpetrator
disarming him I mean this is something
unheard of we're told by the authorities
if you seeed himself he was unarmed I
mean he's a security guard and we know
the security guards are just there like
a scarecrow nowadays they have barely
any rights so this individual where
people are running out with wets and
they're not allowed to Strongarm them
he's put his life on the line jumping on
this man disarming him for the sake of
what I'm assuming is a white woman
protecting and white girl protecting her
from this white as salent this immigrant
this Christian with people are
describing even knifing people has
become very British if you can call it
that and he is you know Allah but
putting his life on the line so these
migrants coming over here you know
stealing our jobs no the migrants coming
over here and saving our girls isn't it
crazy that the whole narrative that's
been PT painted or suggested I think in
the last one 3 four weeks now has been
one that suggests Muslims in particular
are the ones who are the cause of all of
this yes and in both cases you have
people from Christian majority countries
first one Rwanda second one Romania M
okay one in Europe and one in Africa who
have no connection whatsoever with Islam
perpetrating these heus acts one brother
made a good point he said you know when
they assumed it was a Muslim they
started you know pelting the mosques but
hijab when they found out it was a
Christian why didn't they do that with
churches obviously because of their
connection with look this is Prejudice
at its finest this is stereotype at its
finest this is really a contrivance of a
narrative from rightwing Ruffians who
are very angry with themselves really
that's what they're angry about is the
summer holidays they're looking at their
lives and they're very angry with
themselves they haven't achieved what
they wanted to educationally familiarly
economically financially in any way and
they are the bottom of the Barrel in
terms of British society and they need
somebody to be upset with they need a
scapegoat they need to project onto
somebody they need somebody to to look
at and say the other The Impossible
subject they need somebody else to say
this is the reason why we're failures
and they have chosen two major subgroups
the Muslim Community and the qu
quotequote immigrant Community but in
both cases this is immigrant Brown
Community like people when drawing
caricatures not mentioning any names but
they depict immigrants as brown people
when over here this guy wasn't Brown at
all in fact he was white that's what it
is and so the the the point is the
Muslim here is the one who saved the day
and isn't this going to Plate some of
you now isn't isn't shouldn't this now
makes you realize that not all Muslims
are the same no no no no being way too
naive here because Tommy Robinson I saw
his tweet and he said look you you got
to give credit or credit is you uhhuh
however he then uh footnoted it
with uh but is if this is his Twitter
page uh he's a bit he's an islamist he
is in other words trying to discredit
him upon let's say he's an islamist for
the sake of argument which we there's no
evidence of it I'm sure you're going to
add but it doesn't dis show what so the
islamists are doing the job that for
example your right-wing Ruffians should
be doing themselves instead of damaging
and destroying the police uh forces and
hurt breaking you know place of worship
and vandalizing them I mean this man
here is unarmed and he's coming he's a
Muslim man so the point I'm making here
is that your narrative has failed this
is a and I think bro this is outside
agenda it's clearly an outside agenda
this is I think it could be a Zionist it
could be a very easily could be a
Zionist agenda funded by somebody
somewhere because why is it the case
that this is all happening now with the
Israel Palestine conflict this is a
question that we have look at Tommy
Robinson no one will deny that he's one
of the main protagonists of this whole
thing of the riots right no one will
deny that okay call them call him
antagonist now for the sake of argument
so how far away is it for us to assume
that somebody like that who's probably
being funded by this group that group or
the other group right has intentionally
put this narrative together and contrive
this to create a distraction with what's
happening in Palestine it wouldn't be
surprising because when Kama came I
think he was trying to recoup some of
the Muslim voters that he lost by saying
if Netanyahu was to come here yes he
would be arrested and you know he
backpedal on a lot of leeway that he had
given to Israel by saying pretty much
greenlighting the genocide that was
taking place by saying yes it's it's
okay he was on LBC saying yeah you know
it's self-defense cutting off
electricity food water self-defense and
he got absolutely shredded to bits for
that some people are saying maybe it
could be a bit of a punishment uh
because of that but again the Zionist
agenda especially with Tommy well T aiv
Tommy Robinson it's very clear I mean
his funding with a basic Google search
with a basic I mean even um academics
have looked into this Professor David
Miller to quote at least one of them has
definitely looked and you know provided
copious evidences of his linked with
zionists um which is undeniable frankly
but you what was interesting with Tommy
Robinson was that he did try to
disparage Abdullah by saying oh he's a
islamist however if you look at that
account that Tommy Robinson shared it
was actually renamed only but a few days
ago before the name was fan of Putin it
wasn't even abdullah's page and only
recently got renamed to Abdullah they're
playing games they're playing games but
the is up because at the end of the
day we're not going to be fooled anymore
uh and and where is Tommy bro why isn't
he here protecting the young girls why
is he sitting in Cyprus with the Irish I
can't believe that they're trying to
create a narrative it's interesting
isn't it that they're trying to create a
narrative where Muslim people um
supposedly are culprits of killing young
girls when when zionists and Western
people with W with with the permission
and sometimes the encouragement are
killing the most western uh young girls
probably in the last 30 to 40 years in
in in in the world bro even if we look
in this country it's white people that
are obsessed with killing young children
Lucy letby killed seven babies and
attempted to kill six she was a nurse
she was white in fact the uh deadliest
mass shooting in British history was
done by somebody called Thomas Hamilton
in 1996 in which he killed 16 pupils
imagine this for I mean that's 96 there
was one recently with this guy called
Jamie Barrow have you heard of that one
and the and he killed three people and
two of them were young girls black
actually Muslim as well he was a white
man his name was Jamie bar no wonder he
was for 44 years I didn't see the right
wing coming out in the streets
protesting that the far right and the
reason why is because bro if it's not if
it's not the other that's doing the
crime they will always look past it
because they need this narrative bro
it's a psychological thing they need
this narrative they are failures in life
they are failures at home they failures
economically they failures educationally
they fail spiritually in every single
way there in every metric that you can
measure they are failures in life and so
what they need because they're bottom of
the Barrel in British Society yeah they
need someone to blame they need to
project they need to scapegoat they need
to say that this is the reason why we
are the way we are so that when they're
sitting eating you know their Kelloggs
uh you know breakfast or having their
fish and chip lunch or whatever it is
that they have for dinner um you know
seriously they can sit there with their
wife watching the East Enders in the
background and they can say look and
she's complaining because she's not seen
you know certain things from him maybe
physically Maybe
let's be real this or economically
whatever it may be and the kid is
outside you know their kid is outside
and no one knows where they are okay
being groomed maybe or something okay
probably groomed by the Glasco 7 maybe
you see what I'm saying because they're
negligent because they're negligent
parents okay and so here we have this
person and then they say and then they
they put on the news and see a brown
person who's done something wrong that's
the reason why I'm in the situation that
I'm in M they need that brown man if
they lived with only white people around
them they would be either they' be
socialists or or Communists and they
just blame the uh the Elites in terms of
the socio economic Elites or they'd be
self-hating or they'd be an increase in
suicide because they would they couldn't
live with themselves this is what would
happen they failures stop using other
communities as a justification for your
own failures okay just take
responsibility for your own failures
start at home you know and things will
get better but this thing this
contrivance of new narrative that
Muslims are this and that and the other
when the two killers or the two
murderers I should say or in this case
attempted murder I don't know right yeah
attempted yeah the two culprits these
two asants were not even Muslim not not
even from Muslim majority countries this
sorry your credit card your victim card
has expired and the narrative now is
dead and the well has gone dry and
that's all I have to to say and I'm sure
that's all Zan has to say I I just
wanted to mention one other thing as
well
with with regards to the glasow 7 yes
now normally I would have let it go and
we would have concluded but the glasow 7
is a very interesting case study because
it was a child SE x uh abuse case uh the
nspcc said it was the worst one in
decades okay yeah the worst one in
decades and if you look at the pictures
of the Glasco 7 they're all white really
BR yeah and uh again they they were
plowing the kids with c
with with drug with alcohol and vile
stuff that I can't really mention in
this video and like you said there was
no marches like you said there was no I
didn't even hear about it I'm sure I'm
sure the far right if you go and ask
about the you know Glasco 7 or Jamie
Barrow or these white culprits they
don't have not heard the name they've
not heard the name of the victim they
don't actually care bro they do not
actually care and it's dangerous because
when you paint all these abusers which
if I'll put the stat St istics on the
screen as well they are majority white
they're majority White and the thing is
that if you paint them out to be brown
or black or and if you look at look at
who is being abused danger look at
there's there's something called a
slavery act in this country and they put
statistics every every year of who gets
abused and it's people from Eastern
Europe it's people from Africa so it's
like okay the narrative that oh we've
got all these white girls being abused
by these Asians the counternarrative is
actually more accurate yeah because
you've got all these white people people
okay going and taking these uh Eastern
European girls uh taking these African
girls Tak and actually trading them you
know trafficking them and so on using
them as slaves modern day slaves and
that's with the admission of those who
keep up those statistics for the slavery
act I think I don't know was 2014 or
whenever that was first uh initiated but
the point is just look at the facts just
look at the facts stop pretending that
this is an issue to do with race or
religion if it is
then it's not Islam that's being
suggested because it can't be in these
last two incidents